- And we unfortunately
live now in this culture
that almost glorifies failure.
Like, we're supposed to
be so happy, oh fail fast.
The average multi-millionaire in the US
has seven different sources of income.
No life will ever be
saved by you responding
to someone who's negative to you.
If you help a million people,
you'll make a million dollars.
The city I'm going to is
so amazing and wonderful,
that everyone else wants to
be here even faster than me.
Warner Brothers, we did
all the movie studios that
were based in New York, we did all
the record labels based in New York.
We all have to decide for ourselves
what our individual dream is.
Because I know, you're all
going to write to me and say,
"I can't believe, my brain's
"like Bradley Cooper in Limitless now."
If you don't make the
choices in your own life,
then someone else is going to
end up making them for you.
So, I'm good at the writing part.
I don't know how to design a hardcover.
- He's an American hedge fund manager,
entrepreneur, and author.
He's founded or co-founded
more than 20 companies.
USA Today named his book, Choose Yourself,
as one of the top 12
business books of all time.
He's James Altucher, and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(swooshing)
- I had failed and succeeded and failed.
I had started over 20
businesses, 17 of them failed.
And we unfortunately live now in this
culture that almost glorifies failure.
Like we're supposed to be
so happy, oh fail fast.
It's like this failure pornography almost.
(audience laughs)
We just worship people who
fail and then somehow succeed.
But I can tell you that
failure is really unpleasant,
and it's much better to
view it as an experiment.
Thomas Edison, he didn't fail 10,000 times
when he was making an electric light bulb,
he just experimented, and then
he made an electric light bulb.
We don't consider that the
guy was lying on the street
about to kill himself
on the every first try.
(audience laughs)
He tried 10,000 times.
Always have a plan B.
Remember, and this is all census data,
the average multimillionaire I the US
has seven different sources of income.
So that means they have
plan Bs all the time.
There's never a question,
"OK, that's not working."
I had a business that I invested in,
a lot of money recently,
and it wasn't working.
But I have plan Bs, like
seven other plan Bs.
So I'm able to say, "OK,
this is bringing me down
"every time I talk to you guys.
"I'm not going to talk to you anymore
"unless you have something
good to say to me."
And they could kick and scream,
"But you put all this money in!"
I'm like, "OK, I'm done
with that, I have plan Bs."
So all the time think
about how many plan Bs.
Notice when I had a job
at HBO, I had a plan B.
Before I left my job at HBO,
I had my company running on the side
for 18 months before I left full-time.
I had a dozen employees at my company.
So always have the plan Bs.
And then it's easy to leave
early in every situation.
Now again, you don't have
plan Bs in relationships.
There's other things there
you have to be careful of.
(audience laughs)
But you know, that's another talk.
You really can't be
around negative people,
or people that are going to put you down.
Who's going to put you down?
It's not the neighbor down
the street, it's your mother.
(audience laughs)
It's true.
Or it's your friend or your colleague.
And if they want to engage
with you in the negativity,
you can't argue with them.
You're like, "OK, I hear you,
I'm going to eat my
food now," or whatever.
It's like for instance, I see this,
I did a Reddit yesterday, a Reddit AMA,
you know one of those
things that's a Q&A thing.
And you see all the
time, people are trying
to say negative stuff
just to get you sucked in.
You see it on the internet all the time.
They call it internet trolls.
You never ever respond to any of that.
Nothing ever good, no
life will ever be saved
by you responding to someone
who's negative to you.
So this is very important,
and the next step
is obviously surround
yourself with completely
positive people who are inspiring to you,
who are supportive of you.
That works very well.
You need to have some
meaning in your life,
so it's meaning in your
life that causes you
to have idea that will help people.
And that's how you create.
There's a saying, "If you
help a million people,
you'll make a million dollars."
So the dollars is like the
side effect of helping people.
First people have to be helped.
Then that means first you have to be
really good at coming up with ideas.
So I always say you have
to have this idea muscle
that you exercise regularly,
so you're an idea machine,
so that you can then help people,
which then in turn helps you
figure out how to make money.
Or you don't even have to
figure it out at that point.
You'll make money.
Waking up every morning and figuring out,
even in a difficult situation,
where the pieces of gratitude are.
So coming into this city
yesterday or the day before,
I was stuck in traffic, and
I was late for something,
and I was like, "Ugh,
you got to go faster!"
But this is opportunity to solve
a difficult gratitude problem, which is,
the city I'm going to is
so amazing and wonderful,
that everyone else wants to
be here even faster than me.
So I'm grateful to be
going into this city.
There were similarities between
all these types of sales, which is,
you get someone to say, you give,
then you get someone to say
yes, so your foot's in the door.
You do anything you can to get the yes.
And then I would always over-deliver.
I kind of left this part out.
I would always over-deliver,
at least initially.
I would work so hard to over-deliver.
Just do something that they didn't expect.
So for instance, I'll just tell you,
on Stockpicker, as an example,
the day the deal was announced,
the day that we officially
launched our partnership,
I released a whole new section of the site
that they weren't even
expecting, which was a Q&A.
Kind of like a Quora-like
sub-site within the site.
And that doubled our
traffic almost overnight.
They were completely not expecting it.
So I always made an attempt,
when I was first building a relationship,
and all through the relationship really,
but it's easiest to do when you're first
building the relationship,
is to surprise and delight.
Always give extra services.
When I was in the web
design business in the 90s,
we did miramax.com, New Line,
Fine Line, Warner Brothers.
We did all the movie studios
that were based in New York.
We did all the record
labels based in New York.
So we were, our sector was
the entertainment industry.
No matter what, we always over-delivered
on every site that we spec'd out,
every time that we had
a meeting with a client,
there was always extra things.
Nobody could ever complain,
"This isn't what we asked for,"
because we always delivered more.
So that was an important part
of being a trusted source,
so that people would continue to use
our services on the next sites.
We all have to decide for ourselves
what our individual dream is.
Don't subscribe to some
mass hypnosis dream
that was designed to get
us to spend as much money
and time on other people's
dreams as possible.
Choose your own dream
and follow that first.
Writing down these 10 ideas a day,
if you do it for three months,
just try it for three months.
You don't have to try it after that,
because I know you're all
going to write to me and say,
"I can't believe, my brain's
"like Bradley Cooper in Limitless now.
"I can't believe what happened
"now that I'm writing
10 ideas a day down."
We all the time have many choices in life.
A great and wise man once said,
"If you don't make the
choices in your own life,
"then someone else is going to end up
"making them for you,
and it won't be good."
It might be a boss, it
might be a professor,
it might be your parents, it might
be colleagues, might be a company.
Someone else is going to
start making choices for you,
and they're not going to be as good
as the choices you could make yourself.
Of course, that great
and wise man was myself.
Being very humble here.
How do you execute, basically?
- (audience member) Yeah.
- So it's like, your
brother, you have a team.
You have people who help you.
You know this as well as I do.
I just had a book come out Monday.
I'm good at the writing part.
I don't know how to design a hardcover,
I don't know how to do
the interior design,
I'm not actually that good at
picking the title of a book.
I'm not that great at marketing.
I didn't know how to make an audiobook.
I didn't know how to do anything.
So I outsourced every
single piece of that.
And by the way, I also got a pre-order
of 5,000 copies of the hardcover
to completely pay for all of
the expenses I had on the book.
So the book itself to
publish it, I self-published,
cost $30,000, give or take.
I completely pre-ordered
to get more than that,
and then on top of that I've
also made more than that
just from the marketing that I outsourced.
To Mr. Ryan Holiday, who you know well.
Does that answer...?
- Yes.
(swooshing)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Malik Sooch asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of James's top 10 rules
meant the most to you, will have
the biggest impact on
your life or business.
Leave it in the comments below
and I'll join the discussion.
And my personal goal with this channel
is to hit a million subscribers,
so anything you can think of to share it,
let people know about
it, spread this video,
I'd really appreciate it.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)